MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
It's my pleasure,
privilege and honor
to welcome to the
Google campus, swami
Dayamrita Chaitanya, Executive
Director of the M.A. Center.
The M.A. Center is a
nonprofit Institute
in San Ramon,
California dedicated
to spreading the message of
love and compassion spread
by Amma, also popularly
known as the Hugging Saint.
Dayamrita's first name literally
means [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
which means "compassion"
and "nectar,"
or "someone who swims in
nectarian compassion."
So it's only rather
fitting that he
has chosen to speak to us
Googlers about how compassion
can help us become
better humans, personally
and professionally.
But that's not how
Dayamrita Chaitanya
thought his life would go.
During undergrad days
he studied physics
and he was very
interested in film,
so he enrolled or a
master's in film technology
in the prestigious Film and
Television Institute of India,
and he thought he
would end up becoming
a documentary
filmmaker, or maybe even
better, a Hollywood celebrity.
And then in 1983, he met
his spiritual teacher, Mata
Amritanandaymi,
also popularly known
as Amma, the Hugging Saint, a
simple fisher-woman who went on
to become a very well renowned
humanitarian around the world.
And he was struck by her simple
message of love and compassion,
and serving others through
love and compassion.
And he was so moved
by her message
and how she lived
this in practice
that he gave up his film
career to dedicate himself
fully to her work, to
her humanitarian projects
around the world.
And in 1993, he was
ordained as a monk,
and for the last decade,
Dayamrita Chaitanya
has been the Executive
Director of the M.A. Center
where this organization,
this nonprofit,
spreads Amma's message
of love and service,
or compassion and action,
throughout the Western world.
And he's done and led a
number of projects here,
including projects in Haiti
during the earthquake,
New Orleans during the
New Orleans disaster.
So therefore to talk about
how to live compassion
on a day to day basis, and
how it can transform us
inside out, personally
and professionally, please
help me welcome to the
Google Campus once again,
Swami Dayamrita Chaitanya.
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA:
Thank you so much
and good afternoon, everybody.
I've been watching some of
the online YouTube videos
about how Googlers have be
doing some compassionate action,
so I might be preaching to the
choir, so please forgive me.
Many of us have
discussed and meditated
upon the meaning of
life, and life by itself
is meaningless to some.
Yet, one can make a beautiful
life by living it meaningfully,
and what makes life blossom
is how we live and attribute
the meaning to it.
We spend most of our lives in
pursuit of material happiness
and fulfillment of
desires, and yet,
after fulfilling
many of it we still
feel the void and
lack of contentment.
So as some great people
have defined, or tried
to define what life is, there's
a famous author W.M. Lewis,
he said, the tragedy of life
is not that it end's so soon,
but that we wait so
long to begin it.
And there's another great
salesman, and he said,
I think everybody should
get rich and famous
and do everything that they
ever dreamt so that they
can see that's not the answer.
And the most
beautiful quote comes
from the famous Indian
poet, Rabindranath Tagore,
and he said, the
most important lesson
that man can learn
from life is not
that there is pain
in this world,
but it is possible for him
to transmute it into joy.
So while we ponder
about the solution
to the modern day
problems, everybody
agrees that compassion
is the perfect solution.
And what is compassion?
There's so many definitions
to it, but very simply
put it's love plus
action is compassion.
And my master, Amma, she
says's that there are two types
of poverty in the world today.
The poverty due to the
lack of material wealth,
and the poverty due
to the lack of love,
and if we solve the
second one, which
is the poverty due
to the lack of love,
then naturally the first
one also will be solved.
In one sense, we
have role models
for everything today, a
great football player,
a great scientist,
a great movie star,
what we lack is a role model for
a great compassionate person.
And when we talk about
love in this world,
most of the love that we
experience in the world today
is selfish love.
Few people know how
to love selflessly.
We love the cow because
it gives us milk,
and as long as it gives
milk we will love it,
and the moment it
stops giving milk then
we do not hesitate to
send it the butcher.
And the love also that
we have for one another
and for the worldly
objects are like this.
It reminds me of a story.
A woman, accompanied
by her husband,
went to the doctor's office
and after his checkup
the doctor called a wife
into the office alone,
and he said your
husband is suffering
from a very severe disease
combined with horrible stress,
and if you don't
do the following
your husband will surely die.
And each morning, you have to
fix them a healthy breakfast,
be pleasant and make sure
that he's in a good mood.
And for lunch, make
him a nutritious meal,
and for dinner prepare an
especially nice entree for him.
And don't burden
him with chores,
as he probably had a
hard day, and don't
discuss your problems
with him, it will only
make his stress worse.
And most importantly, you
should satisfy his every whim,
and let him unburden
his problems onto you
and he should have no stress.
And also, be especially loving
and affectionate towards him.
And if you can do this for
the next 10 months to a year
I think you're husband will
completely regain his health.
So as the wife went to
the doctor's office alone,
her husband was curious.
So on the way home the
husband asked his wife,
what did the doctor say?
So the wife just
replied very coolly,
he said you're going
to die in 10 months.
So what does selfless
love mean then?
[INAUDIBLE] in the
dark about this
while we have such stark
examples of selflessness right
in front of our eyes.
Now, we have not become
aware of such examples.
If you look at nature
it's serving us
without asking
anything in return.
24/7.
And even while
cutting down a tree,
it gives us shade and
protects the person
who's cutting it down.
And it is thanks to nature
that our lives are sustained
and we have fresh air to
breathe and pure water to drink
and the temperatures are
sustained so that it does not
affect life here on Earth.
And yet, we abuse
and exploit nature
though nature gives selflessly
without expecting anything
in return.
And compassion and
selflessness go hand in hand.
Only if we have selflessness
does compassion work.
Compassion is also love
without expectation.
A compassionate person does
not expect even a thank you
from the person to whom they
have offered their help.
And we have different degrees
of love and compassion
is the highest and the
purest form of love
that a human being can
practice in day to day life.
It is recognizing
that the person is
a part of the sum
of your whole being
and not looking at them
as separate from you.
So what is the difference
between helping someone
and being in compassionate
service to them?
Now while helping
somebody you always
place yourself in a higher
pedestal and the person whom
you are helping in a lower one.
And knowing that
they need your help,
but as in a
compassionate service,
you place this other
person in the same level,
or you place them even at a
higher level and serve them.
So why should we
practice compassion
in our personal and
professional life?
Most of you are already aware.
A compassionate person
is more productive.
He brings happiness, not only
to himself, but to others too.
And mind you, there
is a difference
between a compassionate
person and a happy person.
A happy person is one
who feels temporarily
fulfilled and content, whereas
a compassionate person is
one who does not care about
temporary happiness that
is brought through the
fulfillment of material
and emotional desires.
And no amount of material wealth
can bring contentment also.
Just think about you
take the two richest
people in this world.
You know who they are.
Who are the two richest
people on the Forbes list?
Bill Gates is the first one,
and the second one is Carlos.
And Bill Gates has
an asset, which
is equal to about $160 billion,
and Carlos Slim, from Mexico,
he has an asset worth
about $150 billion.
And last year, actually Carlos
Slim was the most wealthiest
because he had $170 billion and
Bill Gates had $150 billion,
and now he has been promoted
or demoted to the second rank.
So just think how he feels
when he compares himself with
Bill Gates.
Will he feel rich or poor?
Because he is only $150 billion
instead of $160 billion,
which is what Bill Gates has.
So in one sense,
what makes us rich
is not the amount
of material wealth,
but what we have is that, as I
said from the contentment that
gives from the giving and
not from what we receive.
And how do we practice
this in our daily life?
Just simple things like
thinking about daily that you
will do one good deed a day.
So when you come into the
office and sit at your desk,
most people think about the work
that is piled on their desk,
right?
And they rarely stop
and tend to look around
at the person
sitting next to them
and ask them how they
are doing or if they
are having a difficulty.
A big smile makes
a huge difference.
Going back home also, you
can practice compassion
in your daily lives.
My spiritual master gives
the example of surgeon
who goes to the hospital
and does so many surgeries
on people, saving many lives,
and then goes back home.
And what if he behaves like
a surgeon at home also?
What if he starts cutting
open his children?
Or doing something to his wife?
So in our day to
day lives we have
to take so many different
roles, and choosing
the role which is most
beneficial to the other person
is also compassion.
Sometimes you might
ask this question.
I have to be strict, and I
have to be stern to people,
and what will I do at that time?
So definitely, we have
to see that is also
another form of compassion.
Like once a person went to
my special master and said,
he's written a book, what
should he do with this book?
So my master said,
just go and give it
to this such and such person.
And here she will read the
book and give you suggestions
as to how the book will be.
Now, after she read
the book-- she was also
a disciple-- she looked at the
person straight on his face
and said, you know, this
book is of no quality
and what you have
written is rubbish.
But what happened
was of course the man
should have had a heart attack,
but instead the man took
it very humbly and he completely
rewrote the book, which
became a best seller later on.
So compassion is
also discrimination
as to what the person
whom you are serving
needs at that moment to hear.
And also, helping nature
is also compassion.
Do something which
is good for nature.
My master often tells
people to just grow
vegetables in their home
and just getting good food,
and then it's not only good for
the nature, it's good for us
also.
Also, we should think
about why action is always
a part of compassion.
So we should try to
act and do something.
So when we ask this question,
what is the greatest
benefit of compassion, and
why should you do this,
why should you practice
this every day?
Because whatever you give,
it comes back to naturally.
There's a beautiful story.
Once there was a lady doctor
who was driving on a freeway,
and it was a dark night.
And it was a very rainy
night, it was very cold,
and suddenly, her car
stalled and she was
lucky to pull over to the side.
And as she was waiting
there she called AAA,
and AAA said that it will
take at least half an hour
to two hours for them to come.
And it was a very busy
night, and a lot of people
had requested for so
many calls, so they
said it probably will be
anywhere close to two hours.
So as she was standing there,
there were so many cars
zooming by and not
even one car did stop.
And finally after 45
minutes one car stopped,
and as she was looking
at her rear view
mirror she saw a big guy
getting out of the car
and he was walking
towards her car.
And the moment she saw him,
she started getting nervous.
And the first thought
that went into her mind
was does this person know
that I'm alone and I'm a lady
and then maybe he wants
to rob me and take away
all my possessions.
But as he came nearer, he just
gently knocked on the window.
And as she opened the
window he asked her, ma'am,
what happened to you?
Can I help you?
And she said, oh, I called
AAA, and he said look,
I know what it is,
tonight is a rainy night
and there's so many demands,
it might take you to two
to two and a half three hours.
They say two hours, but
it might take three hours.
But I'm a mechanic,
and I will try
to see what's wrong
with your car.
So reluctantly, the lady
agreed and then he said,
why don't you do something?
Your car doesn't even start, why
don't you go and sit in my car
and you can just sit there
in my car, comfortably.
So the next thought that came
into the lady doctor's mind
was oh, now I know why,
he wants to steal my car
and go run away with it.
And he wants to give
me his old Toyota.
So then as she was debating
whether to go or not,
finally she conceded and she
went to his car and sat there.
And half an hour later
the car began running
and the man came back and told
her, now your car is running,
but one thing, just make sure
you just goes straight home
and tomorrow morning you
can take it to the mechanic,
but please don't
drive any further
because I'm not sure whether
the car will run further.
So as she was going back
home, she started thinking,
why did I doubt this
person unnecessarily?
He was such a nice person.
And the other thing
that she was doing
was also, as she was about to
go she started offering him
some money.
And he said no, no,
there's no need for money.
I didn't do it for that and I
don't want any money from you.
Just don't worry about it.
So as she was driving
home, she started thinking,
why did he do this?
Why did he do this action?
So what left her pondering for
two weeks as to why he did it,
and then she could not sit
quiet unless she returned
that favor to somebody else.
So she was looking
for an opportunity
to do something
to somebody else,
and it was two weeks later as
she was sitting in a restaurant
and she saw there was a
waitress who was serving there.
She was clutching her stomach
and she was running around
and doing things.
When she saw her, she
was immediately reminded
of this person and said I should
try to do something to her.
So she went and asked
her what her problem was,
and the waitress said look,
I'm supposed to deliver a baby,
and we don't have
insurance and my husband
has gone to bring
some money and to pay
so that I can get
admitted in the hospital,
and I don't have any money.
And so I'm just
waiting for my husband,
meanwhile I'm having
all these convulsions,
so I don't know what to do.
So the lady doctor
said, will you
please come with me immediately.
I will take you to
my hospital, and I
will deliver the baby myself.
Don't worry about the
money, just come with me.
So meanwhile as they were going
the waitress called her husband
and told her that there's
a kind doctor who took her
to the hospital and such
and such a hospital,
so he should just come there.
And the doctor
delivered the baby
and three hours later, the
husband rushed inside the room
to happily see the
mother and the baby.
And after having the
moments with his child,
he suddenly started
thinking about how
he was going to pay back for all
the service that was rendered.
And he was about
to get up and run,
and then he asked
his wife look, I
don't know how to pay
for all the services
that has being given to
us, what should I do?
So the wife smiled
and said you know,
the doctor said there
was no need to pay,
and she has paid everything.
So the husband was
so surprised and he
asked her, who's that doctor?
I want to meet her.
Let me go and meet her.
Just tell me her name.
So it was at this moment the
doctor walked into the room,
and both of them just
looked at each other
and just talked for a moment.
And tears were running
out of their eyes.
You know who it was, it
was the same lady doctor
that he had helped earlier.
So when we are young, we
dream of accomplishment.
We want to be innovators.
We want to be champions
of great causes.
It hardly occurs to us to
practice the smaller steps
of connection along the way.
One kind word, one
considerate action.
A considerate action
on a daily basis
will broaden our experience, our
understanding, and perhaps even
our opportunities to reach
our more lofty goals.
And so, what we
have to practice is
in baby steps, a kind action,
a kind word, a kind deed.
It's like this story of a
man who was walking along
on a deserted beach at sunset.
And as he walked, he could see
a young boy in the distance.
As he drew nearer, he
noticed that the boy
kept bending down, picking
something up and throwing it
into the water.
And time and time again, he kept
hurling things into the ocean.
And as the man
approached even closer,
he was able to see that the boy
was picking up starfish that
had being washed on the beach.
And one at a time, he
was throwing them back
into the water.
The man asked the boy,
what he was doing.
And the boy replied, I'm
throwing these washed up
starfish back into
the ocean or else
they will die through
lack of oxygen.
But the man said, look,
you can't possibly
save all of them.
There are thousands
on this beach,
and this must be
happening on hundreds
of beaches along the coast.
You can't possibly
make a difference.
And the boy looked
down, frowning,
for a moment then bent down
to pick up another starfish,
smiling as he threw
it back into the sea.
He replied, now, I made a
huge difference to that one.
So I'll just stop with
one of my favorite quotes
by Ralph Waldo Emerson,
the great poet,
and he said, the purpose
of life is not to be happy.
It is to be useful, to be
honorable, to be compassionate,
to make some difference that
you have lived and lived well.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: The story of the
mechanic and the doctor,
that's not bound to happen.
So what is it that comes
around that is bound to happen?
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA: No,
that's actually a true story.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
it will not happen
in a million years again, or
in a thousand years again.
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA: I'll just,
as an example of what I said,
whatever you give,
it comes back to you
in one form or the other.
So I'm just trying to sell
compassion in one way.
Like you are all trying to
sell so many products here,
I'm trying to sell compassion.
That's my job.
I was doing that,
and by doing so,
I'm illustrating
through this story
that it is bound to happen
to you when you help somebody
or you will definitely get help
from some other person totally
unknown.
And I've seen this again
and again a thousand times.
So I am sure that
it will come back.
That's what I meant.
MALE SPEAKER: But then
it's not selfless.
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA: No,
but it becomes selfless
when you don't expect it to
come back, but what I'm saying
is that when you do it without
expectation, definitely
it will come back to you.
AUDIENCE: Certainly
doing good deeds
on a daily basis,
even small ones,
is a way to practice compassion.
I'm wondering are
there any other ways
that you can really
practice it to get
yourself to have that awareness,
to make it a habit to do that?
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA: See,
most of the time what happens
is we are thinking
about ourselves, not
the other person.
I've seen my master, who is
an embodiment of compassion,
she sits and hugs people
and one time what happened
was as she was hugging one
person he was about to get up
suddenly he just got up
inadvertently, and went and hit
her head and both their head's
went and hit each other.
And usually what happens
when our heads get hit,
the first reaction is our
hand goes and covers our head
and starts rubbing it.
And what I saw was instead
of covering her own head,
she went and started
rubbing his head.
She didn't think about herself,
so most of the time that's what
happens to us, like we
are in a place where
we think about ourselves and
not about the other person.
So what you can just
start doing as an exercise
when you are with somebody
else, think about what they want
or what they would like to be.
How can you help, in one sense,
give them some kind of thing,
or do something
to them which will
make their lives a
little more happier.
AUDIENCE: I was
interested in what
you said about how if we
solve the poverty of love,
we solve the poverty of
material goods as well,
and I believe that,
but I also believe
that being in a place of
privilege where you have
enough material goods
maybe that makes it easier
to be compassionate and to
think about these issues.
And I'm just wondering
what you think
about the relationship
between taking care of people
materially and
taking care of people
in terms of teaching
them compassion.
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA:
Of course you
know we have to take care
of people materially,
I'm not saying that, but from
a wider perspective that's
what I was just saying
that first of all,
we have to have love
for what we are doing
or for what we are
giving to them,
and it also starts with
compassion to them.
That's why are giving.
Otherwise you would
think, why don't I
just go and see a
movie, or go to the bar.
Why should I just spend
my time doing something
for the other person?
I'm wasting my time.
So unless and until you have
that kind of a compassion
and love then it's not going
to materialize into action,
so that's what I was saying.
I'm not saying that you should
not do it material-wise,
because of course
there's a famous Indian
[INAUDIBLE] swami.
He said, you cannot talk
about spirituality to a hungry
person, because the first thing
that you need to do it feed his
hunger, and you should
not talk to him,
you should not give him advice
without feeding him first.
So it's like that.
So you have to take care
of their physical needs,
definitely.
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
that even kind of forms
from under the first question.
A lot of people tend to
be very, very logical,
and they end up being a
little skeptical of some
of the stories you tell.
What have you seen in your
own journey that really helps
connect with people like
that that may just be,
oh that's very, very improbable,
or that won't really happen.
How can you really share
the message with them
if they take a much more
skeptical view, versus somebody
who may be more open-minded
to the spirituality
of mindfulness?
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA:
It's a good question,
but first of all, we
have to be convinced
about what we are talking
about, and we have
to come from the heart
and not from the head,
and it's not just an
intellectual analysis of what
I'm telling you today this
is also my experience.
I'm sharing with you my
experienced after having
being with so many people, after
having served so many people,
and these stories come from
experience, my own experience
and from the heart.
And if it doesn't
come from the heart,
you cannot convince people
if it's coming from the head.
And second thing is,
as I said earlier,
people are always
skeptical, but when
you tell them with an
open heart and if they
are ready to hear
with an open heart
there's always a
small opening there.
And they might think
oh, perhaps there's
some truth to what
you're saying,
so you have to
give them a chance.
Definitely you have to give them
a chance to open their heart
and widened the
horizons of their heart.
So you have to
have that fate that
they, one day or the other, they
will have a small opening where
they will be able
to listen and then
be able to pour themselves
out and do something.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're persistent,
you have a chance of catching
them at the right time?
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA: Right.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm Igor and I have a
question about expectations.
So you mentioned that it's
important to void expecting
some outcome, or
something that comes back,
so I know about myself and
about some other people,
that a lot of people actually
feel that something is missing.
We want this,
we're missing that.
Any tips on how to
avoid expectations,
about how to avoid expecting
a return, something in return.
DAYAMRITA CHAITANYA:
Correct me if I'm not
answering you properly.
There's beautiful
words in Bhagavad Gita
says you should do
your action and don't
worry about the result.
So without expecting
the result, you're
not going to do an action.
Correct?
But the thing is, I'll tell
you an example of this.
For example, you are
going to meet a friend
and ask him for some
money because you're
in need of money, so
you want like $2,000.
Correct?
So what happens is, I'm
just saying an example,
and what happens is he
can give you $2,000,
or sometimes if he's
in a very happy mood he
says oh, take $4,000 and
don't worry, don't return it.
Or the other thing is he
can say, I have only $1,000,
I don't have money, or he could
say I was going to come to you
and ask money from you.
Correct?
So there are
different scenarios,
Selfless expectation
means expectation thinking
about the possible outcomes.
So what happens is
the beauty of that
is because whatever outcome
that comes, you're not depressed
or you're not
crying, you are not
worrying about what the
outcome is, because you already
know that you're
already expecting
what the expectation would be.
So it's kind of just
trying to understand
what will be the results
of your expectations.
I'm not saying that you should
not have expectations, so just
have an awareness that
whatever expectation,
there are different
forms of results to that.
So I'll just do a very
quick two to three minutes,
so kindly said straight.
Before you close your eyes,
try to look at the ceiling
or just have a vacant stare
and slowly try and become
aware of your breathing
process inside
and whatever is happening
inside the body.
Let's try to follow each
and every inhalation
and exhalation
that occurs within,
and try to breathe normally.
And as you slowly and
slowly breathe and become
aware and more and more aware
of your breath and the process
your eyes will slowly
close without any effort
from your part.
Then you feel
completely relaxed.
And slowly start
feeling the light--
area of light
inside your heart--
Which is the center of the
body, not the physical heart,
but the spiritual heart.
And as the light slowly
starts spreading and filling
your whole being,
imagine that you're
being filled with love,
with bliss, with peace,
with compassion.
And feel each and
every cell in your body
being filled with that light.
And feel every cell
reverberating with love,
with peace and with compassion.
And imagine your whole
being completely immersed
and just becoming one with
that light, and only the light
exists.
Now visualize the light
going from your heart
towards the whole world, to
all the beings in this world,
to the nature, just like
the rays of the sun.
And imagine this light, just
like the rays of the sun,
going out to all the beings,
and as the light falls
on each and every
being, imagine they also
become more loving,
more peaceful, and more
compassionate.
And imagine this whole world
and this whole universe
to be filled with the light of
love, peace, and compassion.
MALE SPEAKER: And with that
I'll close up this session
and wanted to once
again thank swami
Dayamrita Chaitanya both
for the work he does
in the world, his humanitarian
work and his message
of compassion, and for taking
the time to come to explore
this topic with Google.
Thank you so much.